it's been almost a decade since Marvel's
iron man made superhero movie skeptics
sit up and take notice and the
comic-book movie crazy isn't going away
anytime soon there are a slew of
superhero flicks scheduled to hit
cinemas over the next few years but its
franchises continue to expand it becomes
harder and harder to keep track of
what's happening and who's who wait a
minute you guys are the real Avengers
Hulk gives it away this is everything
you need to know about upcoming
superhero movies through the end of 2018
Thor Ragnarok Chris Hemsworth will
reprise his role as the hilariously
heroic Asgardian God in Marvel's Thor
Ragnarok and Tom Hiddleston will be back
to make sure no new villains take over
his spot as number one fanboy villain
though you'll face stiff competition
from Cate Blanchett's the British Oscar
winner comes on board is hella goddess
of the underworld who might just be the
best Marvel villain yet the film takes
our cue from the surreal visuals of
Doctor Strange and looks like it's being
pulled right out of the comic pages
which is a good thing and with director
Taika Waititi at the helm
Ragnarok November 3rd 2017 release date
can't come soon enough
Thor agrees I'm not optimus to know what
are you doing wizard Justice League if
the future of DC films relies on any one
project its Justice League the eagerly
awaited team-up of DC's greatest heroes
could make or break the extended
universe after its rocky start equaling
the success of Marvel's Avengers is the
basic goal for DC here and directed Joss
Whedon is on board to help make that
happen
Whedon is agreed to Shepherd Justice
League through post-production will also
shoot some additional scenes still
aiming to the original November 17th
2017 release day Ben Affleck Henry
Cavill and gal gadot will be joined by
Jason Momoa
and Aquaman Ezra Miller and the flash
and ray Fisher a cyborg Irish actor
Ciaran Hinds confirmed that he's playing
classic villain step
by a motion-capture with one of
Darkseid's main men finally on screen
can Darkseid's be far behind and will DC
films finally lighten up a little just
like about a jillion we host our black
panther while we're not sure how the big
screen version of Wakanda will differ
from Stan Lee and Jack Kirby's
comic-book vision of a high-tech jungle
world we'll find out from February 16
2018 after a handful of screenplay edits
and juggling directors Marvel secured
creeps director Ryan Coogler and this is
a real for Black Panther which recently
screened at Marvel's Los Angeles
officers reportedly had everyone excited
joining chadwick boseman as black
panther will be Lupita Nyong'o Forest
Whitaker Angela Bassett and Creed's
Michael B Jordan who said that Black
Panther will be a very honest and gritty
movie how that will fall in with the
comedic action fair like guardians of
the galaxy and ant-man is anyone's guess
but with any circus evil ulysses klaw
showing us anything is possible New
Mutants Fox has handed the reins of the
x-men spin-off franchises don't make a
Josh Boone who admitted to being
obsessed with Marvel Comics he took it
upon himself to convince the studio to
put the nubbins on the big screen and
alongside karada Nate Martin they put
together their own Newman's comic books
based on stories they wanted to adapt to
Fox the studio loved it
Fox recently confirmed a release date of
April 2018 with Game of Thrones vet
Maisie Williams signed on to play the
hairy mutant Wolfsbane and the witch
star anya taylor joy signed on to star
as magic sister of the excellence
colossus stranger things start charlie
hidden will portrays a jet-powered butan
cannonball 13 reasons why actor Henry
saga is signed on a sunspot and newcomer
blue hunt will take on the part of
Native American mutant Moonstar rumor
has it they'll be up against one of
Marvel's weirdest villains and one of
the early adversaries that demon bear
and everyone knows that there's a
I'd use tickity cut that Varitek's like
a freakin country Bear Jamboree around
here Avengers infinity war good news
impatient Marvel fans infinity war will
be a standalone movie and not broken up
into two films released an excruciating
year apart as originally thought
directors Joe and Anthony Russo cleared
up the confusion admitting that the
working titles were misleading and will
see it all on May 4th
2018 MCU fans know to expect to see just
about every Marvel superhero appearing
in a battle against Thanos and
behind-the-scenes footage from Marvel as
confirmed star-lord actor Chris Pratt on
set with Robert Downey jr. and Tom
Holland brie Larson's Captain Marvel is
also set to make her MCU debut Marvel is
positioning the two upcoming Avenger
flicks as the culmination of everything
they've been working toward since the
first Iron Man movie dropped in 2008
Marvel's Joe Russo confirms the hype his
next two Avengers films will be an event
like no one has ever seen on film before
Marvel Studios head honcho Kevin Feige
also addresses their well documented
villain issues fairness shows us why he
is the biggest the best the baddest
villain that we've ever had what should
we expect an infinity Wars sequel the
Russo's have revealed that they're
considering as many as 67 well-known
Marvel characters to round out the
film's incredible roster the title of
the sequel was being kept under wraps at
Marvel though guardians of the galaxy
stars Zoe Saldana recently dropped a
huge hint by mistake and we all have to
go back for gauntlet later this year
does that mean Avengers 4 will be called
Infinity Gauntlet all we know is that
one of those 67 Marvel characters had
better be MODOK
Oh seriously Busan cut baby arms and leg
Deadpool to 2016's Deadpool became the
highest-grossing film in the x-men
franchise keeping the creative team
together for the follow-up seemed
essential but director Tim Miller has
departed the sequel allegedly because
star Ryan Reynolds didn't back his
demands for a larger budget David Lodge
of John wick Fame has stepped up to
direct and Josh Brolin will be welcomed
into the fold as the Merc with a mouth
time-traveling foil cable Jack Cassey
best known as philandering rocker
Gabriel Valley bar in FX vampire series
distrain has reportedly signed on as the
villainous mutant black Tom Cassidy and
because it wouldn't be dead bull without
his reluctant action gentle side geeks
stefan kappa kikz and brianna hildebrand
will returns as michalak x-men colossus
and his understudy
negasonic teenage warhead prepare to be
offended in the best possible way on
june 1st 2018 The Incredibles 2 after
veering off into live-action Pixar
legend Brad Bird is set to return to his
bread and butter with a follow-up to his
2004 animated superhero smash The
Incredibles a second outing with the
path family was first announced in 2014
a decade after the original film with
the 2019 release date penciled in when
pressed for details but said I don't
like unwrapping presents before
Christmas the film is very actively
moving and we're excited about we're
trying to take it into new directions
just a few months later Frozone actor
samuel l.jackson was posting photos to
instagram from his Incredibles 2
recording sessions and the film's
much-anticipated release date had been
moved forward to June 2018 with Toy
Story 4 pushed back to make way ant-man
and the wash Kevin Feige recently
confirmed that the sequel to 2015's
ant-man would go into production in
summer 2017 would be aim being to wrap
in time for a release by July 2018
Michael Douglas confirms that he'd
returning as Hank Pym and he won't be
the only returning member of the
supporting cast with Michael Pina and
David Gus mulch and also set to reprise
their roles alongside Paul Rudd and
Evangeline Lilly in the
Rahl's returning director Peyton Reed
seems excited about the film
particularly about introducing the wasp
to the MCU saying for me as a comic nerd
I always thought of ant-man and wasp as
a team and that's a lot of what the
second movie is really about to show her
finally fully formed in this movie is
really exciting
then sony has been trying to produce a
venom movie for over a decade but we now
finally have confirmation that the
studio is prioritizing the project
pushing for an October 2018 release
powerhouse Tom Hardy has signed on to
play the lead role of Eddie Brock the
first villain to take on the Venom
symbiote suit in Marvel Comics so I only
confirms the casting when they Twitter
the photo of Hardy wearing a venom
t-shirt along with the caption that
revealed production is set to start this
fall directing duties have been offered
to zombie lands Ruben Fleischer
producers are hoping Hardy is better
received by fans than Sony's previous
venom played by Topher Grace as Hardy
set to play a central role in what
they're calling the Sony Marvel Universe
party we'll be working from a script
penned by Scott Rosenberg and the
amazing spider-man 2 co-writer Jeff
Pinkner x-men Dark Phoenix Fox's
announced the 12th film under X
franchise based on the life and death of
Jean Grey loosely centered on the events
around the uncanny x-men story arc of
the same name and the cosmic force
responsible for gray going a little
crazy x-men Dark Phoenix is set to open
in November 2018 few other details
unknown at this stage though an
Instagram post from James McAvoy
suggests that she'll be involved the
Scott snapped himself having dinner with
fellow Professor X actor Patrick Stewart
and longtime franchise producer Simon
Kinberg captioning the pic I can't wait
for the summer which is when production
is scheduled to take place Aquaman DC
fans got the first glimpse of natural
born badass Jason Momoa as Aquaman in
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice last
year and they'll be seeing him again in
next year's Justice League before his
first solo flick hit screens while the
casting seems solid question marks
remain over Aquaman after a series of
destabilizing changes behind the scenes
and whether it will meet
it's December 21st 2018 release date DC
Comics is already adjusting Aquaman's
papered counterparts to look and act
more like memo is big screen king of the
sea so we'll be getting a pretty good
idea of what to expect when he finally
makes his real debut in Justice League
one thing's for certain however no one's
going to make fun of Aquaman after this
no one
[Music]
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]
[Applause]